and we have a fox news alert a grand
jury returns a 16-count federal
indictment against
empire actor jesse smallett for his hate
crime
hoax joining us now with all the details
raymond arroyo fox news contributor new
york times bestselling author of the
brand new book will wilder
the amulet of power raymond wow this is
a
talk about a whiplash just a month ago
when people were
thinking they were roving bands of of
mega-hatted
wearing guys going into metropolitan
areas looking for uh gay black men to
beat up laura just a week ago we had
major stars tyler perry members of the
empire cast terence howard and others
coming out defending him this is
devastating 16 counts federal grand jury
and it's not only for falsely reporting
a hate crime
it's for other charges here that he has
yet to answer
this looks really bad for him yeah they
should and the question is we're going
to entertain this throughout the block
should he be off the show permanently
given the severity
my god well here's my question when
the entire nation is transfixed
where you you could have triggered riots
right that's what the the police were
saying on on this show not citing hate
and inciting hate dividing again people
against uh
each other and and the fear that that
put
in the in the hearts and the
consciousness of americans especially
minority americans
that in and of itself is unconscionable
then roping in as a conspiracy you're
open to other people
you write a check you write a check for
something that that you know
a lot of people can be interested it's a
conspiracy to create
hate and to drive more hate and it's
just what we didn't need
in the pop culture and in our politics
all right we have a lot more to get to
tonight here
on uh the ingram angle when it comes to
this uh the crazy news and the culture
there are calls to stop playing
michael jackson's music after the airing
of that explosive
huge hit that hbo documentary leaving
neverland
so what's the story well millions of
dollars laura is the story
sony just paid 250 million dollars to
distribute all of michael jackson's
catalog
there's a popular vegas cirque du soleil
show featuring his
songs and image but with the arrival of
this documentary
where two victims allege horrific sexual
abuse at jackson's hands
all of that is imperiled bear in mind
these two alleged victims
knew michael jackson as minors they
sought money from the jackson estate in
and their claims were thrown out they
also testified on jackson's behalf
when he faced similar allegations in
2005.
at that time they claimed they were
never abused now even corey feldman who
knew jackson when he was a boy and stood
up for him right
is backing away from his support for the
king of pop watch
i don't want to be perceived as i'm here
to defend michael because i can no
longer do that
i cannot in good consciousness defend
anyone who's being accused of such
horrendous crimes
see so what's happening now is even the
simpsons producers
are pulling back an episode in which
michael jackson's
voice was featured now this is kind of
virtuous signature okay let me just
worse
and oprah interviewed jackson right well
she interviewed him in 1993
interviewed his family when he died now
so they cashed in on him when he was
living
now they're cashing him when he's dead
this is a big problem
the media lord and we'll see this again
and again
they are they are hedonists while these
people are being built up
then they turn into puritans when they
fall i'd rather we invert the paradigm
and police these people while they're
big stars
and you know it ties in nicely with this
horrible case of r
kelly that we're seeing who also went
down in flames
over a docu-series at lifetime we had
that we had the docu-series last uh
you know last in january last month uh
surviving r kelly but
should we and this is the question we
opened with should we stop
listening to these people well if this
is okay
i'm not defending anyone i don't know
what happened i i have a problem
with relitigating someone's life when
they're not there when they're dead
i have a problem with that jackson stood
trial for these charges i mean it's not
like he didn't like
okay but again maybe it's because i grew
up listening to the jackson 5
or thriller and it's kind of part of my
youth and all but it's part of the youth
of
the entire country so now to say
the the artistic product itself is toxic
boy we have a lot of songs and a lot of
artists right that we better get a big
where's my sharpie a big sharpie pen
and go through the entire sony catalog
and
all the catalogs you got cr you got
chris brown okay
beat rihanna you've got uh you've got
jerry lee lewis married his 13 year old
i'm going to see jerry lewis and later
let me jerry jerry
and then bing crosby remember crosby
beat the kids with the strap with the
metal spikes
i don't think we think of any of that
when we hear white christmas we just
don't but
i i but i don't know where this ends
well this where does this end there
they pull down statues they're they're
they're trying to remake history
they don't let people live in the
current time
and then look at history and individuals
with the with the
wisdom that we've got we've gathered
they have to destroy it all the music is
about us the music is about our
relationship with the time it's often
nostalgic and it captures a time for us
it's not about these people so when you
see our kelly you know we watch this
this week these two
women who are living with him apparently
they interviewed with gayle king watch
us quickly
how do we say this without being
inappropriate is this a
three-way relationship or do you each
have a separate relationship with him
how does this work i'm curious yeah
we both have our individual
relationships with him and right we all
are family
all together we have our moments where
we sit and watch movies all together we
go to amusement parks all together
i'm not talking about azeroth going to
movies and sitting watching uh going to
parks
i'm talking about is it is it a
three-way sexual relationship actually
well
first of all i'm not here to talk about
my personal life and i would never share
with no one what i do in or outside of
the bedroom
and as a woman i'm sure you would not
either there are people all over the
world who have multiple girlfriends
it's no different it is different you
know the problem is the man is a
degenerate r kelly's a degenerate of
course he's engaged in these horrible
things
we should condemn it on the front end
and choose your icons
wisely and certainly don't take moral
lessons from them by the way laura yeah
i'm at nyu 7 30 saturday night
oh at my alma mater talking about will
wilder doing a book signing
at 238 thompson street right on
washington okay and you can find out
more information on your facebook page
and
on twitter so that's great so that could
be fun in new york
if i'm protested i'll bring the video
all right fantastic